today we're going to discuss how to burn
more fat while you are sleeping
now the first thing to know is that if
you're going to burn fat it's going to
happen at night now during the day
if you weigh yourself before you go to
sleep and then compare that to when you
wake up versus when you wake up and
compare that to the end of the day
you are going to find if you use a
special scale that you are going to lose
a little bit more at night and hardly
anything during the day you burn fat
when you're relaxing when you're resting
when you're repairing but what i want to
talk about is how to
turn that dowel up how to burn more fat
while you're sleeping so when you go to
sleep at night you actually go through
four different waves of sleep from a
superficial level to a much deeper level
and there's like four different waves
that you go through it's in the deeper
delta wave where you're burning the fat
and what triggers that is this hormone
called growth hormone and growth hormone
is the main fat burning hormone it's the
hormone that helps to
mobilize fat from the fat reserves and
help you use that for energy and repair
so then the question is how do we get
more of delta wave sleep so you can get
more growth hormone well there's many
things you can do related to sleep but
one is making sure that your room is not
too hot if you're slightly cooler you'll
get more into a deeper restful sleep so
i keep my temperature about 65 to 68
degrees now the next thing is you want
to make sure your room is very very dark
so there's no light coming in because
darkness stimulates melatonin and
melatonin triggers
growth hormone okay and that's going to
help you sleep so this is why you
wouldn't want to be on your cell phone
or your computer right before bed you
don't want to expose your eyes to blue
light so the best thing before bed is to
maybe read a book or you know if you're
going to watch tv make sure it's comedy
it's not the news or some thriller or
some action movie that's a big mistake
if i watch a comedy by the time it's
nine o'clock i am like ready for bed now
i know that might sound early and that's
just me but
as long as you're getting to bed before
11 o'clock you'll be in much better
shape because the way these circadian
waves work is that if you miss the first
wave 90 minute wave and you go to bed
after 12 o'clock now you have to kind of
wait until that wave catches you for the
next wave so in other words if you're
tired and you don't go to bed and you
you push through it
and now you're awake then you have to
wait 90 minutes before you can catch the
wave and get back into the next wave of
sleep so there's various hormones that
are triggering sleep that are in a kind
of a wave pattern there's a couple other
things i'm going to mention about sleep
when you go to sleep a lot of times what
keeps you up is
thinking about things right you're
you're solving problems
i recommend taking vitamin b1 before you
go to bed you can do it through
nutritional yeast or a b1 supplement but
that will greatly help kind of turn off
that
conversation that is going on and on
your brain a couple other really good
nutrients to take right before sleep are
vitamin d3
like 10 000 international units that is
going to help you reset your circadian
wave it's also going to get rid of pain
if you're trying to sleep at night and
you have pain
that's going to inhibit your ability to
sleep also zinc before bed is a really
good thing as well now if you get up at
two o'clock in the morning
and you can't get back to bed that means
your cortisol is too high so one thing
you do is focus on your breath make sure
that your the inhalation is the same as
the exhalation and so whether that's
five seconds four seconds three seconds
just
make sure the timing of the inhalation
matches the exhalation you can focus on
your breath as you're laying there as
you're trying to get back into sleep and
pretty soon you'll be waking up
realizing that you just
slept okay so
that's what i would recommend and then
if you do get up at two that means you
need to focus more on your stress and
work on that i have a lot of videos on
that i'll put some links down below if
you have that problem so if sleeping
enhances fat burning insomnia inhibits
fat burning and the number one thing
that makes you not sleep is stress
probably one of my best tips for stress
is to get outside
get in nature
and do physical work of some type some
type of productive work that you can use
your whole body and you can actually
get tired that would be something i
would highly recommend if you can't do
that then do some type of exercise that
will counter the stress now if you have
pain i already mentioned this vitamin d
is the best remedy for pain especially
if it's in your lower back if you have
leg cramps that means you need
electrolytes because leg cramps can keep
you up as well so any leg cramps check
out the link down below i have a very
specific video on that now the next
reason why people can't sleep is they're
getting up urinating several times a
night uh that means you have insulin
resistance in which case you need to go
on keto and do intermittent fasting but
the main thing with that is the snacking
late at night that is the killer
you need to stop snacking at night in
fact i wouldn't recommend eating past 6
30 and i wouldn't recommend drinking any
liquids past 6 30 just drink a lot of
liquids during the day but not past 6 30
that will give you plenty of time to
make sure your bladder is not filled so
you can go to bed and sleep with the
whole night it's going to help you lose
my weight all right number two
exercise
not just any exercise but vigorous
exercise will help you burn more fat
because it's going to increase more
growth hormone what is the term
vigorous what does that mean
it means done with force and intensity
so i wouldn't do a little light thing
very quick you want to actually do
something high intensity a lot of force
that will cause your body to get sore
the next day so whatever that is
that's what you need to do you see when
you exercise
you don't burn any fat right away what
you're doing is you're tearing your body
down you're stressing it out
and then in the recovery phase
when you're sleeping is when you burn
the fat
and if you want to burn more fat you
want to do more vigorous
exercise full body intense
short duration
lots of rest
try not to over train high intensity
interval training it's called hit is
another great uh pattern of exercise i
have videos on that i'll put the links
down below but exercise will definitely
help you burn more fat while you're
sleeping now one nullification that will
completely nullify your workout here you
spend you know half hour or an hour
putting all this effort in
and the last thing you want to do is to
pretty much cancel out your ability to
burn fat you want to make sure that you
don't nullify that and
one big thing that will nullify it is
consuming
food
before during or after the workout as in
a protein energy bar as in a protein
shake as in a carbohydrate sugar shake
okay so you don't want to consume any of
that stuff around the workout now you
can do electrolytes if there's no sugar
but don't do any protein amino acids
it's not going to help you you have
enough protein in your body to repair
at night it's not going to happen anyway
during the day so why are you going to
waste your time the purpose of exercise
is to stress the body break down
everything so you can heal the next
night or the next few days so don't eat
anything before or after the workout
and in fact if you combine number two
exercise with number three
fasting this is the next topic
you can create some serious uh weight
loss when you're sleeping fasting is
probably the most potent thing to help
you lose weight especially when you're
sleeping because you can increase growth
hormone by a factor of 2 000 percent
when you're working out you're only
increasing growth hormone at a max of
700 percent so
fasting is way more powerful and i would
practice intermittent fasting as well as
periodic
prolonged fasting to really spike that
growth hormone so you can lose more
weight while you're sleeping now a
couple cool things about fasting it's
very cheap in fact it costs nothing it's
free you're not eating you're going to
save a lot of money if you reduce the
frequency of meals like i'm going to
recommend
you'll save at least 500
a month just on food
and you'll probably have some of the
biggest health effects that you've ever
had in your entire life one being fat
loss but there's a lot of other benefits
cognitive improvements improvements in
mood
decreasing risk of cancer and other
diseases but a really important thing to
combine is
to exercise while you're fasting okay if
you can do it that would be a very good
thing but what would determine that is
if you work out
and you still can maintain the level of
intensity
without that food that means you've
fully adapted the fat and you should be
doing that but some people
they lose their
strength when they work out while
they're fasting simply because they
haven't adapted yet so that does take
some time in which case i would work out
around the meal either right before or
right after you eat when you do fasting
you stimulate something called the
parasympathetic nervous system and
another name for the parasympathetic
nervous system is
rest and
digest
you're going to be able to feel calm
you're going to be able to rest much
better and you're going to be able to
burn more fat
you don't burn fat when you're in the
sympathetic flight or fight mode
when you're in stress mode you don't you
burn fat when you're in a relaxed
state so if fasting improves fat burning
while you're sleeping then frequent
eating is the killer
in burning fat while you're sleeping and
it is so you don't want to do that you
want to do intermittent fasting what
will turn off fat burning faster than
anything is carbs even a little bit of
carb also eating in general will turn
off your fat burning simply because
eating triggers insulin all right as far
as your macros go
what do you do with your carbs well i
would not count your vegetable
carbohydrates i would have big salads i
would try to count the other carbs and
make sure they're below 20 grams per
day not per meal
but per day that's going to be very very
important
now as far as the fat goes i would
recommend not adding additional fat to
your your diet i would only have the fat
that is with your meats okay
that means not adding additional fats
from some keto dessert
or your bulletproof coffee
or
mct oil you can put a little cream in
your coffee but don't add additional
fats why because we're trying to go
after weight loss and if you add
additional fats your body is going to
burn that for energy and not your own
fat reserve
so in other words keep your fat kind of
in the moderate amount
not excessive all right what about
protein
20 of your calories should be protein so
i would recommend anywhere between like
six to seven
ounces of protein per meal if you are a
female and you're younger and you're
smaller
maybe three ounces of protein and of
course i want to hammer this home
all it takes is a little bit of
carbohydrate to block a lot of fat
burning all it takes
is
a little snack before bedtime or a half
a glass of wine
or a handful of nuts or maybe a little
bit of ice cream before bed
to completely cancel out all the things
that you're doing right during the day
the previous day let's see you worked
out you ate healthy and then you had
this little
carbo snack guess what
all those great potential benefits are
nullified
unfortunately i'm sorry i'm just the
messenger okay so
next point is stress in cortisol when
cortisol goes up
your weight loss goes down
stress alone is probably equivalent to
eating sugar okay because stress
increases cortisol cortisol
another name for it is called
glucocorticoids because it helps you
regulate glucose and so if your cortisol
goes up
your fat burning goes down you have to
avoid stress some of the best things you
can do for stress like i already
mentioned would be physical
work
outside you know in nature that would be
great long walks
very very very important all right
number six there are other things you
can do to trigger
more fat burning while you're sleeping
and this mainly is focusing in on
triggering growth hormone okay
number one niacin that's vitamin b3 can
help you trigger growth hormone arginine
which is an amino acid can help you
trigger growth hormone and lose more
weight
zinc
increases testosterone and increasing
testosterone will then increase growth
hormone okay zinc is a good one oysters
have the most zinc red meat has zinc two
creatine from red meat also can trigger
growth hormone okay so don't think red
meat is bad but just make sure consume a
moderate amount not high protein because
that can inhibit weight loss as well
there's another natural thing you can
take to help increase growth hormones
called dhea this is good to take when
you're getting older menopausal or just
over the age of 50 when your dhea is
going down because the adrenals are
weakened you can even take it as a
supplement to increase growth hormone
all right the next thing to take to help
you not just with sleep but with a
growth hormone is vitamin d vitamin d3
can help
make sure you take at least 10 000
international units all right and then
lastly we have potassium and magnesium
two powerful electrolytes that can help
calm your body allow you to get into a
restful sleep
and burn more fat potassium and
magnesium are both
natural physiological
tranquilizers they're they calm the
nerves they help your muscles repair
very very important to take that
especially if you exercise during the
day but just make sure you don't take
that in electrolyte form right before
you go to bed because it's going to make
you urinate because it's going to get
rid of excess fluid all right then
there's two last points i want to bring
up there's things that inhibit growth
hormone one is xenobiotics that would be
like the pesticides insecticides
herbicides fungicides
so you want to eat more organic
because all those things can stimulate
things like
estrogen and lower your growth hormone
and your testosterone and create
problems so you want to eat really clean
and if you're on medications okay that's
a real big blocker for growth hormone
and fat burning there are quite a few
people that just can't lose weight
because they're on medication i've done
about five thousand videos on various
topics and a lot of these topics include
overcoming health problems you can do a
search and find out the best remedies
for that all right if you haven't seen
my video specifically on growth hormone
i put it up right here check it out